only fans the subscription service known
for adult content has banned explicit
context so let's explain what that means
not explicit content explicit conduct
yesterday bloomberg reported that only
fans is going to prohibit users from
posting any material that contains
sexually explicit conduct starting in
october i.e people having sex or
pornography so it's very strange because
only fans sent a statement to a few
media sources like bloomberg and dan
primrack at axios who was an excellent
journalist but they didn't share it with
the creators or users and then dan
tweeted a screenshot of the statement
which was called fake by multiple people
in the replies and then because only
fence obviously hadn't shared anything
yet and then dan purposely cropped out
the only fan's employees email address
and a screenshot from the statement it
appears the content creators will still
be allowed to post
nudes right and videos even if they
remain consistent with only fence policy
but
sexually explicit conduct will be
prohibited i.e people actually having
sex i.e adult entertainment or
pornography so there's some semantics
here that have people confused content
conduct et cetera that's pretty obvious
and only fans had a cleverly worded
statement basically saying sexually
explicit content is okay we support you
exclamation point and then makes them
look like the good guys obviously but
they're banning sexually explicit
conduct pornography which is how many of
those creators make money and obviously
during the pandemic we all know
that a lot of people who were
sex workers which i think is the
positive framing of
prostitution that a lot of people have
come to i'll let you make your own
judgment on that i have my own feelings
but who cares about my point of view
that sex work moved online and then that
was safer for people obviously if you're
not going and
meeting random people off of craigslist
or whatever services i think backpage
had been shut down at this point
if you're not going to meet with people
you take out a lot of danger and maybe
you make more money and you do it safer
in the comfort of your own home without
taking risk obviously
and everything else that comes from sex
work so only fans doesn't disclose how
much of their content is adult related
you may have remembered that story about
the millennial influencer bella thorne
made a million dollars but she wasn't
actually doing sex work on the site in
fact i don't think she was naked that
was a big controversy but this has
become
uh a very big site and a source of
income for a lot of people especially
during the pandemic when people couldn't
go out to this led everybody to ask the
obvious question why is only fence doing
this right this is their golden goose
this thing is printing money for them it
turns out that the payment systems the
banking partner are giving them pressure
and so the journalists here and we've
talked about this on this program a
bunch and we're going to keep talking
about it since i am now covering the
news i'm going to talk a little bit on a
meta in a meta way about journalism
because i started as a journalist i had
two magazines cyber surfer then
siliconangle reporter and then i started
web logs inc which created engadget
autoblog and joystick with brian alvey
peter rojo said ryan block and sean gold
so i had a nice have a nice history of
doing as a publisher and a journalist so
i understand how this works journalists
are trying to triangulate on the truth
you can think of them as detectives
they're following clues and trying to
figure here's what's probably happening
here according to bloomberg and other
people only fans is having problems with
their banking partners they have to
rein people in on the service and it
might be that
legal action has been taken against them
maybe there's underage people performing
on only fence because what is the
vetting process to get on only fans how
do they know that the people who are on
only fans performing
whatever acts or being naked or not
underage and then how do you deal with
different ages of consent in different
regions when this is an international
service it's a can of worms obviously
and there have been other uh situations
like this recently because of course
you're thinking to yourself people go to
stores to buy pornography why can't they
go online to buy pornography and isn't
it
better that the
adult entertainment companies are not
taking all this money paying a flat rate
to
adult entertainer sex workers and they
get to keep all the margin you're
literally taking out the middleman in
that case which will be the adult
entertainment company the studio
produced content versus ugc user
generated content the studio actually
has a function there they are going to
verify that people are of the right age
and
they will go to jail if they don't and
they have legal liability etc so while
they are taking a huge fee and that
could be unfair
there could be other issues so there
could be some issues here around vetting
problems this is super complicated we
live
in a world where these services get very
big and it might be that only fans is
managing uh the service in the review
mira in the same way youtube does
youtube would let anybody post anything
and then if they got complaints they
take it down okay so if snl has lazy
sunday stolen and youtube benefits from
that
okay that's one level of problem or
legal issue copyright infringement if an
underage person is involved in sex acts
okay now we're talking about child
pornography that's a different level of
evil
and people are going to go to jail
rightfully so for the maximum long
amount of time we hope
so the quote from only fans because of
all this in order to ensure the
long-term sustainability of our platform
and the cont and continue to host the
inclusive community of creators and fans
we must evolve our content guidelines
now remember visa and mastercard
suspended payment processing on pornhub
due to pirated content and at-risk
amateur content the thing i've been
describing here right because it is a
wild west on these services and pornhub
responded um by only allowing verified
users which makes total sense
how you police a service like say medium
or blogger.com or wordpress or youtube
or vimeo or tiktok is going to be
radically different than how
you would uh regulate adult
entertainment or
finance
that's why regulations are coming to
things like only fans and to crypto this
is actually a parallel trend we're
seeing here people create things on the
internet they grow very fast they get
big fast then they have unintended
consequences those unintended
consequences have to be addressed and
let's face it technology has a big
tradition of move fast and break things
which which is sometimes referred to in
our industry as better to beg for
forgiveness than to ask for permission
okay if you're airbnb and you take that
approach because you're reinterpreting
the laws for who can rent a room that's
one
level of risk what is the risk if i rent
you know my apartment out okay could get
trashed okay somebody could bother my
neighbors those are actual risks sure
that's different than somebody getting
fleeced in an ico scam so many people
did or the horrible nature of what could
happen
in sex work so they have over 130
million users that only fan and they
have two million creators let that sink
in for a second there are two million
people using the service to make money
and i think it's primarily of those two
million i would think
a large percentage of them are doing
some kind of nudes or adult
entertainment they're currently trying
to raise that evaluation over a billion
according to bloomberg they did two
billion dollars in sales in 2020 and
they're on pace to double that in 2021
according to sources they take 20 which
means 400 million in revenue in 2020. 20
is less than the app stores take but a
lot more than airbnb say takes so it
seems like a fair rate as we call it in
the business the take rate or a rake
r-a-k-e patreon takes five to twelve
percent they've been incredibly generous
with theirs and then gumroad we had
sahil on the program back in the day
they take eight point five percent or
six percent depending on if you use your
paypal etc
as founders investors and executives we
spend so much time building up the
companies and products that we love and
care about but at the end of the day
life is fragile and it can get taken
away at any moment that so it makes
sense why people get life insurance
especially term coverage which is
surprisingly affordable why not pay a
little bit each month to protect the
ones you love it's a no-brainer if
you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder makes it really fast and
easy to get covered you just need a few
minutes and a phone or laptop to apply
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find out instantly if
you're approved and that's one of the
great things about the service it's just
so quick and easy to use there are no
hidden fees you cancel any time and
since life insurance costs more as you
age
now is the time for you to cross it off
your list and make sure it's there so go
check out ladder today and see if you're
instantly approved you'll find out very
quick go to ladderlife.com twist again
l-a-d-e-r life.com twist that's
l-a-d-e-r
life.com twist ladderlife.com twist to
see if you'll get approved do it now